no matter how different we are from each
other everybody has a shadow it is a
constant companion always with us no
matter where we go unless where we go is
in a room with all the lights off of
course as a child shadow seemed
mysterious or even terrifying but as we
get older we learned that shadows are
nothing to be concerned about just your
body blocking light of course at the scp
foundation nothing is what it seems and
a shadow is never just a shadow near an
abandoned air force base in afghanistan
nestled next to a set of human remains
the foundation discovered an unusual
object capable of turning a simple
shadow into a prison
scp-272 is an iron nail 11.5 centimeters
in length covered in engravings of an
unknown origin the engravings have not
yet been identified or traced to a
specific civilization but the research
staff assigned to the object have
described them as captivating but scary
it was discovered during a sweep pulled
out of a rock face by a member of
foundation personnel at first he
believed it to be an ordinary nail until
he dropped it suddenly for no apparent
reason he was unable to move from the
spot he stood there calling out for help
for 20 minutes before another member of
personnel picked up the nail and he
regained full range of motion
scp-272 like many other objects in
foundation containment is almost eerily
mundane aside from the engravings on its
surface the nail looks like any other
nail you might find scattered on the
ground its true nature only reveals
itself if you happen to drop it
determined to learn more about the
nail's properties limitations and
potential unknown adverse effects the
foundation conducted a series of
experiments the first experiment was
conducted at the discovery site for
scp-272
the rock face in afghanistan a d-class
referred to as
d-272-01 was handed the nail and
instructed to hammer it into his shadow
in the area of his feet once the nail
was two-thirds into the rock zero one
was no longer able to move he attempted
to run but could not lift his feet he
stood there sweating and immobile until
he collapsed from heat stroke at this
point a researcher intervened and
attempted to carry the unconscious man
out of the sun no matter how hard they
tried his body could not be moved until
they removed the nail zero1 was taken to
a hospital and administered fluids and a
medical exam and testing was suspended
for the day after determining that the
nail immobilizes its victims by trapping
their shadows and them in place the
research team wanted to test the
limitations of this effect if the nail
needs a shadow to work then what happens
when there is no shadow present a new
d-class 0-2 was selected and brought
into the same discovery site this time
however they went after dark at
approximately 10 pm the nail was dropped
at zero two's feet and embedded itself
in the earth without needing to be
hammered then zero two was instructed to
walk 10 meters away from the nail he
managed this easily with no adverse
effects the experiment was relatively
uneventful until zero two attempted to
flee the scene and was terminated for
his escape attempt the body was disposed
of and the research team made note of
their findings the nail does not work if
the subject is not casting a shadow so
if total darkness kept the nail from
working and bright light meant it worked
completely what would happen if the
light changed in the middle of the
experiment two hours before sunrise the
very same night another d-class was
brought into the site the subject zero
three was instructed to walk away from
the nail in a straight line until he was
told to stop two hours later when the
sun came up all hell broke loose zero
three was pulled into pieces as his body
attempted to make its way back to the
direction of the nail by any means
necessary his legs were yanked back
towards the nail and were collected
several feet from it his torso on the
other hand was located 106 meters away
from the nail with signs of road rash
and severe trauma three cleanup teams
were required to remove all evidence of
the carnage the nail was removed to test
facility 25-h and the team decided to
put an end to any further
experimentation involving sunrise
several lighting-based experiments
followed the sunrise disaster all with
relatively uneventful findings the
research continued in this way until one
member of the research team dr cho
posited a new question what happens if
the nail is embedded in two overlapping
shadows two other members of d-class
personnel 0-4 and 0-5 were positioned
under stadium lights so that their
shadows overlapped the nail was dropped
onto a point where the shadows were on
top of each other and promptly embedded
itself in the ground both subjects were
instructed to attempt to move away from
the nail zero five was completely
trapped unable to move her feet or walk
away meanwhile zero four was able to
move freely with no consequences except
for a feeling of a chill so the nail is
only able to hold one person at a time
in an attempt to see if there is a
pattern present in terms of which person
the nail will hold if presented with
multiple options a follow-up experiment
was conducted with eight members of
d-class personnel ranging in age from 18
to 59 years old all eight subjects were
placed with their shadows overlapping
and the nail was dropped onto the point
of overlap the youngest subject an 18
year old boy was held still by the nail
the other seven test subjects let out a
scream when the nail hit the ground and
were reported to shiver throughout the
duration of the test when the 18 year
old was taken out of the study and the
experiment was repeated the second
youngest person in the group was held in
place the experiment was repeated four
more times removing a subject each time
until subject zero seven collapsed from
hypothermia the next experiment was
conducted outside in a grassy field near
the test site subject zero five was
placed on the grass and handed a shovel
once the nail was firmly in the
subject's shadow she was instructed to
dig it out of the dirt zero five began
digging and proceeded normally at first
after 90 seconds however she fell to the
ground screaming in agony a medic rushed
to her side but by the time he reached
her side she was already dead an autopsy
determined that subject 05 died of a
cerebral hemorrhage with no clear
physical cause though it appears that
the attempt to remove the nail is what
killed her the research team decided to
take a break from human trials and take
a closer look at the physical properties
of the nail itself what weaknesses did
it have could it be destroyed subject
zero nine was given the nail and a
collection of tools then instructed to
go to town on the object and attempt to
destroy it zero nine placed the nail in
a vice and attempted to go at it with an
angle grinder as soon as the grinder
touched the nail zero nine fell to the
ground seizing and speaking in tongues
hands pressed to his temples thirty
seconds later he was dead from the same
kind of cerebral hemorrhage that killed
subject zero five examination of the
nail revealed a small amount of surface
damage showing that the nail likely can
be destroyed but is somehow able to
defend itself against destruction
regular human trials were resumed the
next day and subject 10 was brought into
the test facility there one stadium
light was placed on a
computer-controlled track allowing the
light to be shifted incrementally from a
remote point outside of the room the
light was set up to cast a long shadow
and the nail was dropped into the
shadow's head immediately subject 10 was
unable to walk away from the nail in
keeping with the standard effects of
scp-272
then the light was slowly raised moving
the shadow the subject was dragged along
as the shadow moved as if yanked by his
feet he stumbled and had to work to
regain his balance then the light was
moved quickly again the subject was
dragged along with the motion of the
shadow however due to the rapid pace of
the light's motion he was unable to keep
his balance and fell to the floor
receiving scrapes bruises and mild road
rash finally in an attempt to see what
might happen if the subject was unable
to move even against his will ten was
restrained his feet were chained to the
floor and a chicken wire screen was
placed between him and the nail then the
light was moved again did the horror of
the research team watching these
restraints did nothing to lessen the
nails hold on the subject he was pulled
forward violently and the chains ripped
from the floor and his body slowly
forced itself through the chicken wire
landing on the other side in a pile of
tiny pieces like a potato shot through a
tennis racket no matter what is holding
them down or what is in their way a
subject cannot escape the pull of their
shadow or the prison of the nail they
will be bound to it even if it kills
them testing was temporarily suspended
while a cleaning crew attended to the
room taking the rest of the day to get
the blood stains out of the concrete the
final experiment on record was conducted
the following day subject
d-272-04 was placed in the center of the
room with one stadium light casting his
shadow at a 45 degree angle the nail was
dropped onto zero four's shadow and he
was held in place then the research team
simply waited food and water was
provided every few hours as well as a
bucket to use as a bathroom for the
first two days the subject seemed
relatively normal if exhausted and upset
on the third day he did not respond to
food or water when it was offered after
a week had passed the subject began to
speak in rapid manic screams of what was
determined to be a dead language by day
11 the subject was switching back and
forth between bursts of intense ranting
and a catatonic state finally after 14
days pinned to the spot by the nail
subject 0-4 was set free as soon as the
nail was removed they began speaking
english again they were severely
malnourished and visibly traumatized but
immediately began to recover once freed
from the nails hold portions of the
subject's rants were recorded and
translated by dr kimmerow who attempted
to interview the subject on the 14th day
of the study at one point the subject
said i cannot sleep the screams are
heard i am not warm the shadow steals
when asked how he was feeling the
subject began to tear up the skin on his
arms and shout i am the prisoner of my
own foolishness let my flesh crumble
like the apple whose ashes burn at my
tongue
not the most cheerful thing to hear but
not too out of the ordinary for a day's
work at the scp foundation either
following this experiment human
experimentation with scp-272 was
suspended until further notice
scp-272 is kept in a small wooden box
hidden in a vault at sector 25 because
nothing happens to the object as long as
it is left alone no further containment
procedures are considered necessary when
the nail's removed from containment for
experimentation staff have been
instructed to take extra care not to
drop it
scp-272 is considered a safe class scp
due to its inability to act on its own
it does not appear to do anything when
left alone however there is clearly a
great deal more to that little nail than
meets the eye somehow it is able to
wreck psychic havoc on those it traps
and on anyone who might try to harm it
the more we learn about the nature of
scp-270
the more questions crop up where did it
come from how does it get inside
people's heads what did subject zero
four mean by the shadow steels we may
never know but if you find yourself
picking up any strange nails one of
these days make sure you don't drop them
now go check out scp-999 the tickle
monster and scp-978 desire camera for
more of our favorite safe class scps